oh yes half your breasts nice that sweet
sound a sweet sound of joy happiness and
inevitable death lies about to happen
we're gonna play a park that already
exists this is a park that already
exists this is a park it's very cool
very very cool although this park has
height problem too many [ __ ] people
in my Park feel sick and they puke these
people need to be eradicated and so I am
found a great way to dispose of them
this rollercoaster is closed for
business we're going to redesign it in a
way that it will be perfect it's a very
complicated design very fucksake and
that's it that's it that's the whole eco
step now let's make sure we have the
boosters like a launch speed maximum
launch speed very good and now we open
the roller-coaster and the roller
coaster of course is called say or say
sayonara [ __ ]
oh what's that sound that son of a [ __ ]
he threw up but I say yes you son of a
[ __ ] I'll put you here and then we put
a no entry sign right there so they have
to go on the roller coaster
now homo feel sick we'll just put them
all here yeah you feel sick well I enjoy
your final ride [ __ ] you throw up in
my park you will pay the ultimate price
they're all going in yes it's working
you might go any second ah
I'm so nervous oh it's gone it's gone
it's gone it's gone
bye-bye bye-bye [ __ ]
a lot I bet test
that's what happens you throw up in my
pack and I will give tell people only
I've hunted more okay you know what
let's say play normally I'm I'm so sorry
about that
so we defeated forest frontier we
practically defeated dynamite dives
better only bridge that's it so this
this one is really fun because you get a
lot of space but you don't have a lot of
[ __ ] written things to work with all
right this is not a theme park get the
[ __ ] out you [ __ ] [ __ ] let's
start right away with a dope-ass
rollercoaster I think that'd be dope
pretty dope even the land is not owned
by Park oh so I can't even adjust a
bridge ah I can't do anything are you
kidding me [ __ ] you trust me this is
gonna be the coolest [ __ ] roller
coaster that you've never seen [ __ ] come
on there it is there it is you piece of
[ __ ] that's pretty cool I'll let's go
and make it go through the holes am i
right ladies
up top this is pretty cool I'm pretty
proud of this like if my mom saw this
right now she'd be proud she plays
rollercoaster tycoon
so you know I would know what makes her
proud not you right this is pretty dope
it goes back in man
[ __ ] me goddamn it [ __ ] s okay let's
get this gonna be the best you can see
that [ __ ] Island there with a little
piece of [ __ ] duck we're gonna yeah
that's right that's right we're gonna
put that's right we're gonna use it now
we're gonna go round it we're gonna go
right I have plans for it later don't
worry about don't worry about for one
second mate I am so [ __ ] focus can we
do it no no no how then did my
calculations go wrong how
where's say what is the same nine I'm a
knight what do you want about me all
right this is gonna be so cool uh it's
raining it's raining information shots
information charts need to sell a
Braille si si ap up the prices on those
[ __ ] umbrellas man let's give it some
cool edgy color uh-oh oh [ __ ] it barely
made it what a shitty roller coaster at
school is it cool park I like it so far
very shocked very nice about like it you
see this [ __ ] Island I bet you like I
don't know what to do with that Island
because I don't know well I'm pro at
this game look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's cool I know damn it alright
that was that we lost all our money on
that that's okay we can take a loan just
a small loan of a million dollars
stubbled trump will help us don't worry
about it oh all right so dumb I love it
yeah who wouldn't want to go with that
ah ah all right all right look at that
duck just gonna suicide right into that
wall
damnit [ __ ] you all then god damnit
this game is hard man I forgot and now I
wasted $12,000 on a [ __ ] wall well I
don't running out of ideas already this
is great I let's spend some [ __ ] mini
cars so I'm just how is that it too high
what a shitty map ah ok yeah that's it's
a to complete
razor rocks that's it look at that look
at that clean slate just ready to build
this looks like minecraft oh my god
ripoff call notch right now okay so
first up we're gonna build is bathrooms
you want people to get that [ __ ] out of
the way you come there with your
girlfriend
and you're so ready to go on a ride but
of course right away she has to go to
the [ __ ] bathroom you want a name
form a solution kiosk but there never
seems to be enough of those [ __ ]
things like you always end up in a line
right us right away as well so we're
gonna bill not one not two but [ __ ]
one two three four five six
6000 great they're complaining you're
complaining [ __ ] you you're not even
inside my park my park is not open how
can they complain also another thing
that always pissed me off is that
they're the only they have like this one
mascot right take a picture with [ __ ]
Mikio or some [ __ ] like that all right
they always have like one and the line
is huge and you're like I don't really
want to take a picture of Mikey but if
there was no line then yeah I would but
I don't want to look like an [ __ ] and
stand in line to [ __ ] say hi to
Mickey so uh we're just gonna put like
[ __ ] 30 of them all right
okay we're gonna make sure that he can
only walk there okay we're not gonna put
one or two we're gonna put a lot of more
all right I wonder how many we can put
actually them kind of curate Runa
costing me a lot of money by the way but
I care about people's happiness that's
why this is happening okay well I think
20 is enough so the price of my Park is
very free [ __ ] you I can't change it or
you this is some kind of [ __ ] charity
[ __ ] you you know what let's making it
make a test one of the bathroom is free
and the other one will cost one dollar
and we'll see which one is more popular
social experiment here on the poor pi
Channel now to make sure that there's no
stupid lines we're gonna build two of
them like they love it in the in the
gangbang pile they love it
next up you want something a little bit
more exciting are you thinking what I'm
thinking yes you are yes you are indeed
all right let's do this [ __ ] [ __ ]
then it's not complicated it's nothing
fancy but it'll do the job all right
it'll do the [ __ ] job
put some more [ __ ] sakura trees up in
that [ __ ] but just love sakura trees
alright so now that you've gone on that
right you want you want you want to get
something to eat all right that's what
you go theme parks are basically an
excuse to eat a bunch of crap so let's
get you some [ __ ] hot dogs and no of
course we will build more than [ __ ]
one all right they always feel like
three and think it's enough it's never
right now I call it I call this the
sausage hallway
this is [ __ ] awesome look at the
rating it's actually going what the [ __ ]
they like it they'll a like what what
okay sure sure whatever what
yeah who is throw up in my pock
not where I am
you had to play the devil did you don't
worry I'll make it work
help I'm training hilarious
just like that his life was gone forever
so you get away with murder thank you
for watching this video leave a like if
you did and my throat is killing me so I
bet ended here as well it's always stay
awesome rush your trapped your alter at
little minions in my domain